-Okay, guys.
Here's how the game works.
Liam, you'll start the round by
pressing start on this buzzer,
and then you draw a clue
from the top of the pile.
You have to get your partner
to guess the clue
as quickly as possible
then hand the buzzer off
to the person on your right.
You can make any physical
gesture, say whatever you want,
but you can't say any word
in the actual clue.
If you're holding the buzzer
when it goes off,
your team loses that round.
We'll play three rounds.
Let's take our positions. Ready?
-Yeah.
-Here we go.
Jessica, you're there.
-Okay. Exciting.
-Yeah. And that's you, buddy,
right there.
Are you competitive?
-Yeah, I'm really comp--
I'm a Leo,
so I'm ready to roll whenever.
I can talk crap like anybody.
-Yeah, it looks like you --
-You're the worst. You're the
worst. And we're going to win.
-Oh, my gosh.
-That's the harshest trash talk
I have ever heard.
-Wow. And you play NFL football.
Here we go. All right.
You start off.
You press the buzzer
and then take the first clue.
-All right.
-And best of luck, really.
I really hope
you have a good time.
-Okay.
[ Beeping ]
Opposite of really low
singing voice.
-High, alto, soprano.
Oh, my God.
Falsetto.
-Yeah. There you go.
-Yeah!
-Oh, my gosh.
-Wow.
-All right, go.
-That was good.
-Take this, Gronk.
-You're on the ground, and
you're doing a motion like this.
-The worm.
-Yes, yes!
-Wow!
-He's played before.
-Oh, man. It's a Mexican food.
Not a taco,
but a -- a flat taco.
-A burrito?
-With cheese. No. Oh, man.
-Tortilla.
-Yeah, no!
Oh, but it's wrapped around some
cheese, and you lay it flat.
-Enchilada.
-You lay it flat.
-You lay it flat?
-Yeah.
-What do you lay flat?
-It's like a taco on the side!
Oh, man! You can put,
like, chicken in it.
-I'm Australian. I'm Australian.
-I know! I know!
[ Buzzer ]
Okay.
Oh, my God! Oh, my God!
-Quesadilla?
-It was a quesadilla.
I am so sorry!
A taco on the side.
-A taco on the side.
-Wow! I am so sorry.
-Wow.
-That's all right.
-I'm surprised you didn't get it
from "taco on the side."
-That's all right, boo.
We gonna get it.
-All right. Here we go.
That was great, buddy.
All right. Here we go.
[ Beeping ]
Okay, uh, not long pants.
-Short pants. Short shorts.
-Yes!
-Yeah! Whoo!
-Okay, an exercise move
where you go to here.
-Squats!
-There you go!
-Yeah!
-All right.
-They're a type of shoe and --
-Clogs.
Crocs.
-Yeah! Yeah!
-What?!
-Who is this guy?
-Okay, we're not --
When you like something,
you're giving it some applause,
but not fast.
You're going to do it...
-Slow clap.
-Yeah!
-Wow!
-"Always after me..."
It's a cereal.
It's a little leprechaun.
It's a cereal with all sorts of
different marshmallows in it.
-Oh, Lucky Charms!
-Yes!
[ Buzzer ]
Yes! We won that one, too!
-No!
[ Cheers and applause ]
We were on fire!
-He cheated.
At one moment, I thought
you were looking over.
Kind of looked like
you saw his card.
-I never did that.
-I'm gonna have to side with --
I felt that, as well.
-Guys, we're going to play
one more round.
-One more round.
-And this one is worth
10,000 points.
Whoever wins this
wins the whole game.
-Here we go.
-All right, focus up, buddy.
-All or nothing.
-Here we go.
Let's start with you, Liam.
-All right. We got this.
-Here we go. Ready?
-Yeah.
[ Beeping ]
-Um, God. I'm not cold.
-Hot.
-Yep, okay. First word.
Next part -- I'm all...
-Wet. Dry. Sad. Slow.
-I'm a hot -- Ugh!
-A hot dude. Hot guy?
You're a hot guy.
-It's all --
Everything's everywhere.
-Everything's messy. Hot mess!
-Hot mess!
-Yeah! There, go.
[ Beeping ]
[ Laughter ]
-I don't even know the word.
-What?
-Can I pass?
-No, you can't pass!
-I don't know.
-What are you talking about?
-I just don't know. It's long.
It's an instrument.
-Australian instrument.
-It's a didgeridoo!
-Yes!
-What?!
-I knew it!
-Oh! Use the force, you must!
[ Buzzer ]
-Oh, that's it.
There, we got it.
Didgeridoo. We won.
Wow. Didgeridoo.
-What are the rules of that?
Oh, God.
I'm, like, mad.
-Our thanks to Liam Hemsworth,
Jessica Williams,
Rob Gronkowski.